[Music]
even Kendall Jenner makes mistakes I was
drunk
places to put a tattoo the 22 year old
supermodel got the word meow inked on
the inside of her lip in 2016 and opened
up about it
on Thursdays episode of The Ellen
DeGeneres Show it was literally the
first thing that came to my mind I don't
know just like my drunk thoughts Kendall
said the tattoo didn't hurt it's just
like fattiness I don't even know what's
the business or the muscles
I said I'm Michael but it's flesh yeah
but it's not boat like bone hurts really
better and noted that it wasn't her
first tat my first one was a white dot
you got a white dogs I just wanted to
know what it felt like all my friends I
was like I just want to know what it
feels like
the reality star also acknowledged that
she's the only one of her siblings that
doesn't have a baby but Kendall who's
rumored to be dating Detroit Pistons
star Blake Griffin said she's not ready
to start a family just yet I have
moments when I'm like do I have baby
fever like to own a baby right now but I
don't I don't I shouldn't say that but
I'm good like I can wait a little while
longer but I it's it's awesome because I
can play I have all these little babies
to play with so I can play with them and
then just give up that's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]